sin comida ni vivienda antes de la
tragedia más de 6 mil 100 personas en
los tres departamentos más afectados por
este sismo ya tenían necesidades
humanitarias agudas de las que 3.500
sufrían necesidades extremas el
terremoto lo exacerbó sobre todo para
los más vulnerables como las mujeres
sufrimos no tenemos acceso a los baños
nacionales no podemos orinar
todo el mundo te está mirando
necesitamos espacios suficientes para
lavarnos
es difícil lavarse incluso a última hora
de la tarde
como vesta guerrier otros 200
damnificados viven en el campamento de
cambio en donde las mujeres se enfrentan
a precarias condiciones tengo tres hijos
hemos estado sentados aquí bajo las
sábanas desde el sábado no podemos ir a
casa porque nuestra casa está destruida
no tenemos ningún lado donde vivir
además el terremoto acabó con gran parte
de la infraestructura miles de viviendas
hospitales y escuelas quedaron en ruinas
ya antes del terremoto había 44 millones
de personas que padecían inseguridad
alimentaria en haití eso se ha agravado
y agravado aún más por el terremoto así
que la comida es imperativa mucho más de
lo que era antes según la oficina de
naciones unidas para la coordinación de
asuntos humanitarios se necesitan ciento
ochenta y 7.3 millones de dólares para
atender las necesidades básicas de los
afectados por el sismo que dejó
alrededor de 2.200 muertos y 12.000
heridos